an unusual event in unusual times in the
EU candidate hearings at Parliament
civil liberties committee for a new
British Commissioner 12 weeks after the
UK voted to leave the EU taking with it
the previous UK commissioner but it
remains a member until the end of leave
talks so former ambassador and EU
supporter so Julian King pushed his
fitness for the job of security Union
Commissioner danza de men keep clearly
ter who's your new seat when she an
experienced konkret danza de man at
cover her mom Paco who can say Eagleman
solita ha only alone he only London or a
lucas mo apathy on the job at hand he
had this to say given the multinational
supply chains the only way to defeat the
terrorists and criminals is by working
together effectively in today's world
security of one member state is the
security of all the emphasized
priorities like a new anti-terrorism
directive terrorists access to finance
cybercrime and collaboration between EU
agencies m ep's press for more specifics
on among other issues separating
migration from security and the fight
against radicalization the issues of
radicalization security anti-terrorism
the sensitive issues of data and
anti-terrorism are all ones which he has
the capacity to deal with the full
Parliament is expected to vote on the
nomination this week
Oh